E aí
[Música]
e você sabe o que é a transformação
digital e sistema preocupado lugar
central na agenda estratégica das
empresas nos últimos anos eu gostaria
então de lhe convidar para nós pensarmos
juntos em Três Pontos essenciais sobre a
transformação digital empresas
precisarão de promover a sua
transformação digital segundo o que
então é essa tal de transformação
digital e ter soro como é que isso pode
ser feito vamos refletir sobre as
grandes mudanças que vivenciamos como
indivíduos e sociedade nas últimas
guerras esse presente nos últimos 50
anos nós vamos colocar não tem até a
década de 1970 nas famílias que
geralmente é verdade o Piauí na
sociedade nós temos algumas cultura
fortemente patriarcal o regras muitas
vezes impressionare continuar figura 13
E terá 15 beber bem definidos o
concentrado nas mãos de poucos no
trabalho na vida em sociedade de forma
geral essa estrutura se repetir eras uma
previsibilidade pão diálogo concentração
de beber pensamentos e ações mais
unilaterais agora ele presença de 1990
20 anos depois muita coisa mudou né os
relacionamentos ficando mais então mais
10 20 anos também muitas regras foram
flexibilidade fazer aqui eu não
pressionados acabamento transformadas as
empresas no mundo também já era outro o
dia-a-dia da era mais dinâmico as
possibilidades de carreiras as
possibilidades de organização se
multiplicaram com novos mercados e
também mudanças na estrutura
organizacional parece as tecnologias de
paz também começava a invadir as
empresas a promoverem mudanças radicais
e aquelas trabalho EA pressão por
resultados também tava né
e agora está repleta de doces noivas no
chefes das famílias as relações a
comunicação EA são bem diferentes não é
que a nossa identidade presidente da
fértil mente impactado por essa peça
nova estrutura eu não entendi deve mais
bico da Laís posicionador e também mais
aberto mais variável como vírus em como
sociedade nas membranas já melhor com
Deus mas lembrando já melhor como a
mudança pior passamos também a desejar
um novo não perderá no braço as nossas
aspirações de carreira os nossos
caminhos profissionais mudaram de
maneira muito forte as pessoas dessa dá
mais largo até as diferentes
experiências passam a não aceitar mais
doações que sempre são encaradas pelos
naturais fica Vera são percebidas como
obscuras ou sem bem nós sentido
a besta que hoje não está com Jesus
jamais deixam espetaculares né e elas
passam a ser enorme
Já chegamos em 2020 e que dois minutos
já não somos diferentes mais uma vez já
não pensamos e Agimos de uma maneira
distinta e fazemos dez anos é em muitos
aspectos é só os nossos relacionamentos
os nossos movimentos as nossas
identidades elas são intermediadas isso
é mor barbas pelas tecnologias digitais
elas se tornarão até que o registro ano
presente e nos pagam por ele ser anos
nesse ano eu penso também eu quero tudo
eu posso ser qualquer coisa no trabalho
na família na vida social virtual eu
tomo informação eu faço desinformação eu
sou curar suplementar o surgimento do
conversa viva e daqui a pouco eu não sou
mais nada disso
um arranjo de flores servir as nossas
tecnologias não apenas à sociedade o que
os nossos comportamentos mudar mas as
nossas tecnologias transformaram-se
experiencia noite não é mesmo tempo em
que Essas tecnologias influenciaram a
nossa identidade a nossa relação com o
mundo elas estão bem diferente iniciadas
Pelas nossas mudanças no Terra vamos
voltar no tempo mais uma vez rapidamente
a pensar no justamente nas tecnologias
da década de 1970 por exemplo notebruik
as primeiras transmissões de TV a cores
no Brasil primeiro microprocessador foi
criado em 1971 também lançou o seu
primeiro computador isso acontecer 67
mas os escritórios ou dois trabalho
desandaram outubro analógico máquina de
escrever sem parecer tanto no trabalho
burro da peste
a 90 o mundo era outro deve plantas
medicinais tecnologias digitais Windows
barriga rapidamente as páginas da
internet da Cia de liberta inteiras
quarentena culturas e mercados as
empresas começaram as informatizadas nos
conceitos de informática subordinava a
pegar carga começar outra situação os
celulares começaram a avançar esse
presencialmente que horas chegaram o
mesmo bom Parece mesmo best Justiça
encarregado da empresa sem computador
sem conexão com a internet
se você tem aquela pessoa sempre ficar
no celular as redes sociais tão pela
expansão o a continuar a servir a Mega
sucesso seja ruim e você também no
Facebook dor de cabeça criado saber o
que não sabe que eu converso eletrônico
do condutor preconceitos e conhecer
exponenciar smartphone chegaram e
chegaram para mudar nossa vida nosso
jeito de conceito de conseguir e acessar
de criar informação percebe sapatos
aplicativos novas soluções de transporte
alimentação entretenimento comunicação
tudo tudo passa a mudar o ritmo
Frenético da velocidade do digital e um
proporções experienciais já estamos moro
em 2002 abençoar hoje o mundo da
interconexão do Big Data e inteligência
artificial da realidade virtual
aumentada todos temos um Livro dos
Espíritos
e especiais plantas em 3D da manufatura
de chuva nos braços abertos chão da
Saúde segurança serviços em nuvem da
biotecnologia do mundo da
desmaterialização da economia o mundo da
pandemia e o mundo da Incerteza total dá
para perceber porque as empresas
precisam mudar para perceber porque é
que as empresas precisam se transformar
acompanhar essa natureza volátil em
Serpa complexa ambígua abraço mundo das
nossas vidas
é só lembrando as famílias rodar os
relacionamentos sociais mudaram o
trabalho jeito de trabalhar no grupo
também as tecnologias mudaram esse
problema essencialmente e o nosso jeito
de para subir também Google o cenário
competitivo eu tô também a vida inteira
e por isso estamos fala as empresas bem
ser transformar também que horas vamos
se trata apenas de desenvolver adquiriu
plantar tecnologias digitais não escuta
essa transformação ele é muito mais ame
isso nos leva a segunda pergunta dessas
premissas de um Então essa tal de
transformação digital
a transformação digital o processo de
configuração das empresas fecha ser
natureza de inverno mesmo dessas perante
a sociedade dos prêmios do cenário
competitivo da economia da política
brasileiros no meio ambiente e das
tecnologias agora essa reconfiguração
das empresas era o verbo e bata muitos
aspectos tomar ela impacta e envolve as
estratégias das empresas o seu modelo de
negócio seus processos de operação e
gestão dos seus produtos serviços o
petitório de soluções Impacto um base
Claro suas tecnologias necessárias para
lidar Tantas lutas e claro que também
impacta em verme a sua cultura e o seu
modelo de gestão não estamos falando
aqui de mudanças pontuais de uma
coisinha ou de outra vez nós estamos
falando de príncipe
a transformação das empresas para o do
digital pelo ainda receber última
pergunta como é que se pega cerveja
agora como é que a minha empresa pode
fazer a sua transformação digital então
era muita coisa não existe não dá uma
Fórmula Mágica não a receita de bolo que
vai garantir sucesso que vai promover a
transformação perfeito não existe mas
não existem fórmulas prontas em via de
regra para o sucesso mas aprender com os
dois práticas de empresas que tem
aprendido muito com a sua própria
transformação digital essas boas
práticas elas Espero um dia inspirar
serve também de pouca ação ela recebe o
converter esses também nunca completa lá
jeito nós vamos fazer refletir
criticamente e para nos fazer caminhar
Vamos lá elas primeiro restaurante
a intencionalidade estratégica
é importante ter clareza dos motivadores
para a transformação de Bela surpresa
pessoas reais demandas sejam elas
problemas a resolver você vê
oportunidades a explorar mais o que isso
é muito muito importante é a
transformação digital seja dublar e
conectar as diretrizes estratégicas a
sua empresa também e claro é a pegada de
verdade pela autogestão transformação
digital não pode ser Nações horário não
posso formação mundial segundo ele
aparece desenvolver 12 metros digital
sair por aí dando projetos e ações de
uma maneira a matéria é importante muito
importante que a empresa saiba pelo seu
nível de maturidade digital acidente que
reconheça o que já está condicionando e
também aquilo que não tá legal
a todos fique oportunidades identifica
ameaças e a partir daí perto assim criar
um rolo Guilherme o que perigoso demais
é basicamente o mapa estruturado das
iniciativas de transformação de Bella
estabelece pena dar uma visão do Futuro
está crescendo prioridade para mim é um
da gente plantação isso é muito
importante não dá uma relação de uma vez
só
já perceberam assim você já recursos
recurso mesmo para buscar eles pensaram
pensamento dessa receber Dona Helena
muito pelos percursos para um destino
previsto para investir últimas especiais
recursos para você fazer experimentos e
testes que vai gerar certamente
aprendizado organizacional perigosos
para a saúde afirma pesquisa
desenvolvimento e 13 modelo é eu
adquirir tecnologias e plataformas
a quarta referência
a pesquisa de pele parece uma relação
natural funciona a transformação de um
modelo de negócio de processo soluções e
cultura não vai acontecer da noite para
o dia certo é indispensável que haja um
fluxo contínuo de mudanças de leva as
entregas de pequenas vitórias assim é
possível corrigir roupas e tempo real é
possível aprender é possível se
desenvolver continuar noite engajar
experimentar aprender história da luta
referência preço nível de transformar a
cultura a palavra de cultura
organizacional não quero essas
comportamentos ser embora as relações de
poder estrutura organizacional sílabas
complexas minhas Custom divas é possível
transformar em portadores de uma cultura
analógicas uma cultura de consultar
é uma conta antiga do colégio cantora de
cultivo de Muralhas para abraçar uma
cultura de colaboração na procura de
compartilhamento de agilidade de
conexões e demonstração de civilidade é
fácil grupo não mas é indispensável que
que é a transformação digital é uma
jornada exige muito conhecimento pé que
exigem disposição para mudança percebi
lidade param de muita adaptação e
resiliência percebam conduzido
é uma coisa que são três formato
Ultimamente é preciso e você composto
fecha suspensão com pergunta para você
qual é o seu papel na transformação
digital absorver caro da sua empresa e
da sua perdido
é muito obrigado por sua atenção muito
obrigado pelos também